first if I know we're about cooties I'd
hunt with bare feet you got you got
leeches you got spiders they didn't give
I can't I'm worried about snakes
and girls us of us well you should be
yeah especially warm months the last
scene one here's [ __ ] man
I've never been bitten but I've had my
dog's bit in three times with Frank yeah
Frank got bitten three [ __ ] times
yeah Frank and Lucy they both got bitten
you have to get him gonna bring him to
the [ __ ] doctor one time I brought
him to the doctor doctor looked at him
says well I don't see any swelling the
my it might not have gotten him because
he killed the snake I was like I don't
see that thought he's such a psycho he's
not smart yeah he just would charge in
and just snap at things yeah like the
idea that this thing didn't bite him
thing goes well you know if he's feeling
bad take him back in again I bring him
home an hour later his face got it
growing a basketball off the side of it
so having my dog just [ __ ] bring him
back in but it was expensive two months
which is a real bummer because it's
thousands and thousands of dollars for
this anti-venom and if you're a poor
person I mean they want that money right
now I know man yeah I have I have pet
insurance my dog got hit by a car
$14,000 sir thank God for pet insurance
well I paid like nothing I was it was
incredible hmm so pet insurance is a
necessary thing my dog a bit by a
rattlesnake didn't see the rattlesnake
but I heard my dog like that and I went
what the [ __ ] and we're walking back I'm
I've never seen him like it we're
walking back and my dog's tongue is out
and my dog starts weaving and then just
kind of falls over oh Jesus I picked the
dog up I bring that dog to the vet I
thought maybe he got stung by a wasp or
something I didn't know then I was like
this this she I was like I think she got
bit by a snake and she was so swollen
her head was so it left by the time I
got there her head was like literally
looked like a giant balloon yeah so I
said I think my dog got bit by a snake
do you know what's really cool they ever
gave her of anti-venom when I think
about it you know what's really crazy is
the venom is actually digesting tissue
yeah that's what's [ __ ] up like that
what that venom is for give they bite a
snake like a snake
it's a rat rabbit or some [ __ ] like that
it's actually digesting the rabbit so
they don't have like a stomach like we
have there their whole body's just like
one just rot track the things just rot
inside of it they absorb it you don't
get to it yeah dirty monsters do you
ever see that video that I posted that I
got from one of those guys that I follow
on Instagram but they were in the desert
and this big [ __ ] huge fat
rattlesnake had a rabbit and was
dragging the rabbit away
no this lifeless rabbit is being dragged
away by this thing that's as thick as my
forearm oh my god see that yeah see we
can find it good luck finding it
probably four years ago three years ago
four years ago is it found it watch this
so this thing look at this it's got the
rabbit Wow yeah and they closed in on it
and it just drags it away Wow it's
creepy this is a different video I've
had the one that I had it was a bigger
snake and it pulls it away way quicker
but it's just it's just a gross little
animal but then again you need those
gross land you know animals like that's
the same like the argument that people
say you don't want coyotes in your
neighborhood well okay I kind of see
what you're saying but the problem is
you don't want rats in your neighborhood
either stupid yeah and coyotes are gonna
kill the rats like they do right over
this what is this one the mama rabbit
comes and [ __ ] up the snake oh that's
right yeah that's right yeah yeah the
mom rabbit recognizes some [ __ ] is going
down [ __ ] up that snake get off my baby
yeah look at that
yeah rabbits are [ __ ] fierce man
they're rodents man yeah rats a video
where a kid stopped a cat I think it was
like a bobcat a small Bobcat like in a
village was getting attacked by some
snakes and was protecting its babies and
the mom just left
the babies to die or whatever cuz she
knew that she couldn't fight it the kid
just grabbed the snake by the head and
walked it away and threw it like in the
bush came back and grabbed the babies
and gave him back to the mom it was a
crazy video like eight-year-old kid
maybe younger Kratts he was wild grabbed
a snake grabbed the snake it was a 8 7 6
5 8 foot snake 60 foot probably crazy
some kids grow up hard dude no idea when
I was a kid I would grab snakes if I saw
snake I'm going for it
yeah obsessed you look alive I know I'd
grab whatever but I didn't live in a
place where there were poison snakes
well when I lied when I lived in Florida
I was always worried about running into
an alligator we'd run into alligators
and snapping turtles a lot of snapping
turtles some snakes there are some
snakes who'd run in to do the problem
with Florida yeah once in a while
there's a crowd an American crocodile
mm-hmm or they even saying the
Everglades they got a couple miles out
there oh yeah they do a couple the old
Nile Crocs yeah [ __ ] who got them as
in the seventies and they just let them
loose and now they have a viable
population as it sounds what we doing
this almost seems fake because they have
cameras everywhere fake I think that's
what he does it regardless of the fact
if it's a pet Python I would have done
that in a heartbeat as a kid so he's
pulling on it he's got a Python
oh they set this up that's right as I
was pulling back up and seen all the
cuts I think okay it might not be real
this is not real this is a setup
look that kids been grabbing snakes my
whole life yeah he grabbed that thing
expertly I'd make that thing a [ __ ]
holster
that's about did a [ __ ] holster [ __ ]
rings just a bunch of [ __ ] rings or a
Kangol stir [ __ ] into a belt